well for 14 years eight news now  photojournalist bill road did top-notch  work here on countless stories including  i-team pieces our interviews with  stephen colbert and alex trebek what's  cool at school acts of kindness and  every reporter story imaginable bill's  worked on everything he's won an emmy a  few years back but he brought down the  house with this speech reading a letter  to his younger self he may have written  about his future career  you get to meet many people and ask them  fun questions i bet the job pays lots of  money and your bosses are very nice and  always tell you what a good job you are  doing  today was bill's last day we wish him  all the best in his new career as an  educator his talent and sense of humor  will be greatly missed at channel 8  clearly tongue-in-cheek in that speech  right there and uh really a staple here  at channel light it's going to be missed  100 good luck bill we're pulling for you  that's all for us on 8 news now 11 we  appreciate